the right-hander zach davies
who features sinker change-up cutter and
curve six and ten for the 4.91
era has made 17 starts in his career
against the pirates remember he was a
long time brewer so a lot of experience
with this pittsburgh team six and six
443
against the pirates
and yoshi comes up should sue go homered
in the game yesterday afternoon here's
the 2-1 pitch and yoshi hits a fly ball
deep to left center he still hits one
out of here wow that's strength sutsugo
homers again
seven home runs for suzuka in a pirate
uniform and so when they're going to
pitch you away and not give you anything
to pull well go with that pitch he's
strong enough to hit out left center or
right
you know we've seen the home run pulled
for the most part but this one gets a
change up
a little bit up not a terrible pitch not
a pitch that you expect this
but um boy he's just locked in right now
and they might be seeing some balls
landing the bleachers will crow looking
for win number four 88 punch outs in 94
innings he has allowed 20 long balls
want to try to limit the ball in the air
this afternoon at wrigley with that
breeze blowing out the left-handed
hitting center fielder rafael ortega
that one middle and
camel elects to dive to make the catch
crows happy hamill
maybe a
little jarred after that that fastball
ended up down the middle and you'll see
it slicing back to ben gamel slicing
slicing leave your feet make the play
taking extra bases away good way to
start and there's moran and crow gets
another quick out so four pitches in two
cubs are gone here's patrick wisdom the
third baseman
rick tapper
10 pitch hitting for will crow
good inning for crow matt duffy a couple
of hits yesterday for matt who has hit
now in 19 the last 27
duffy gets a hold of one
sends that one back towards the wall and
that will clear the basket tie ball game
there's a little ambush from matt duffy
talks so much about his ability to shoot
the ball the other way
hit line drives not trying to hit the
ball out of the ballpark he will not
quibble that's his first home run since
may may 15th in detroit to be precise
number two on the air for matt duffy
we are locked up at one a pair of solo
home runs to hugo and now duffy for the
cubs answer you just got to remind the
folks
not just a contact hitter
here's the 1-2
then you got the old-timers like this
guy right here jason hayward gone
2-1 cubs
will crow has one of the highest home
run rates allowed in the national league
and he's giving up back-to-back shots
now to the veterans duffy and hayward
for jay hey it's been a while for him
too july 16th the last time he was able
to make the leisurely trot around the
bases he's trying to be a spiked curve
ball and hayward
thumps it
this home run is brought to you by hefty
hefty hefty ultra strong ultra
low price hefty hayward reynolds with
the bases loaded nobody out good chance
for the pirates to tie and take the lead
here
he does there and reynolds out to center
there's grand slam number one in the
great career of brian reynolds what a
beauty for the all-star five to two
buckos on the grand slam by reynolds
when he's over the plate it's getting
hit and that's why the command has kind
of gotten shaky because he's trying to
hit corners he's trying to keep the ball
down because when he's not down and he's
not on the corners
stuff like this happens first home run
since august 14th for reynolds number
22.
and now the ninth guy to the plate here
is hoy park one out bases loaded here's
the 2-2 from davies
grounded to duffy the flip to alcatra
for one over to first double play
to get out of the bases loaded threat
here we go again cubs looking to respond
and now hacked with an rbi opportunity
with a runner in scoring position
one two to half the opposite way and a
run will score rbi in half as ortega
drats home starting to feel like one of
those days at wrigley field might take
double digits to win this one that's
just beautiful work by ian half down two
strikes staying in the at-bat not a bad
pitch at all
the quality pitch
back door breaker change up
one run already in and here comes matt
duffy holmard in his last at-bat his
first ever at wrigley
duffy gets a hold of one sends it down
the line and left and gone
grand slam
matt duffy
matt duffy had 12 home runs his rookie
year in 2015 he finished runner-up in
the rookie of the year boarding to chris
bryant since then he's hit a grand total
of
11 home runs coming into today
two long ones here this afternoon the
solo shot
and now the salami i may have misspoken
earlier when i said it's going to take
double digits it might take 20.
told you we were trending toward taters
his first career grand slam his first
career multi-home run game
line to deep left going back as gamble
leaps up what a catch by camel
on the curve of that brick wall in left
yeah and it was hit pretty well again a
breaking ball great plays above average
plays
that's not easy out there that little
navigating that little corner out there
especially when you have a brick wall
fly ball now can yield a run reynolds at
third with one out
and a fly ball to left plenty deep to
score reynolds you would think he will
make the tag and he will head home and
he will score sacrifice fly for
stallings and the bucks get one back one
run game emmanuel
rodriguez hard throwing righty with a
245 era opponents hit just 157 against
him get it up there in the upper 90s
sinker slider guy defoe one of
baseball's premier pinch hitters
off the glove
and everyone moves up the pirates have
tied it how about that field is up
second and third one out
get up there
with a drawn in infield just into the
game romine
and reynolds is in the pirates take the
lead on that little roller in the
infield they're gonna use their best
piece off the bench remember contreras
who just came back yesterday first game
that he had played in the major leagues
in about three weeks
rope to left
what a play by ben gamel
when the smoke clears
the cubs
would have been doubled up if moran
could have held on to that
ben campbell made one of the most
ridiculously well done catches you'll
ever see
wow is he banged up too i mean now
that's the third one
uh yeah he he feels like he's been in a
car accident
right now as uh they're all looking up
at the video board nobody can believe it
um and and he almost from his back turns
two
and you'll see it here
going to his right diving the balls
behind him when he dives and that's
incredible look how far back he has to
reach
wow flying through the air
two hits and a walk today for frank
chorinos walked rivas singled or take a
walk to load them up
frank schwendell
out
back
[Applause]
he's shaking his head no he can't
believe it one of those days as you said
ron you won't feel secure until the game
is over
ortega
first went back now coming in and makes
the grab
two down
yeah it was ortega or nobody on this one
well done by rafael and down to their
final out now for the pirates
hayward coming on and he's got it cubs
win
11-8 the final
on a pair of grand slams today